nine-one-one with the address of your
emergency where are you right now this
kind of scenario isn't unusual many
9-1-1 call centers struggle to
accurately locate callers on their cell
phones location please but about 80% of
calls made to 911 are made on cell
phones according to a trade group in
2018 regulators estimated that up to ten
thousand lives could be saved annually
if 911 callers just a one minute faster
these problems locating 911 callers are
so prevalent that in 2015 the FCC
stepped in and ordered cell carriers to
fix some of the biggest location issues
over the next couple of years some of
these plans have already started to roll
out but let's look at why this is
technically much trickier than it might
seem first let's look at a county that
hasn't yet adopted at any of these fixes
this is Todd County in Minnesota they
say they don't have enough resources for
new technology for their call center
which is common in rural counties here
carriers triangulate data among cell
towers and send that information to 911
call centers this can cause problems in
rural areas where towers are sparse this
County's 9-1-1 call center also relies
on smart phone GPS chips which use
satellites and can take up to 30 seconds
to establish position together these
technologies can establish where the
caller is within a radius of about 120
meters that's more than the length of a
football field part of the problem is
that both of these technologies work
best when callers are using their cell
phones from outdoor locations the
majority of cell phone calls are made
indoors where these devices are less
effective because rooftops interfere
with signal they also don't address
altitude meaning which floor of a
building a caller is calling from this
is a bigger problem in large cities we
know you know longitude and latitude
where that is but we don't know the
vertical height exactly within the
building where are you and that can take
precious minutes precious seconds where
we want to come and save lives and
render aid and we're unable to because
we don't have the
location so that's the problem now let's
look at one of the ways that's being
fixed one of the FCC's demands requires
that nationwide carriers improve their
horizontal location accuracy to within
50 meters for 80% of 9-1-1 calls by 2021
that's an increase from only 40 percent
of calls that were able to do that in
2017 with FCC deadlines approaching tech
companies and carriers are getting
involved to help solve the problem one
startup backed by three former FCC
leaders created a software called rapid
SOS to help fix the horizontal problem
let's look at Collier County in Florida
which already uses rapid SOS as software
when a caller dials 9-1-1 on a smart
phone rapid SOS says location
information from partners including uber
and Microsoft and phone operating
systems run by Google and Apple is
funneled through rapid SOS and onto 911
dispatcher screens these apps update
their location automatically when phones
passed by Wi-Fi hotspots making the
information much more accurate
dispatchers can then look at two screens
one with rapid SOS and the other with
the original system so obviously Google
Apple over these other leading
technology companies are really good at
locating us the challenge historically
has been is getting that information
into the hands of 911 and first respond
one test by Google found that rapid SOS
reduced the average radius in which a
caller may be located to about 36 meters
about a third of a football field
so now counties like Clark County
Florida can get a much more accurate
location coming through this system
leveraging all the different sensors in
a callers phone rapid SOS has already
been deployed in more than a third of
the 5,700 9-1-1 call centers nationwide
that covers over 60% of Americans rapid
SOS is just one of many companies that's
come up with a potential solution others
include Google's Android emergency
location services and Motorola's
solutions call works but these
technologies aren't a blanket fix for
now the software can only locate callers
along horizontal lines meaning they
can't send dispatchers data about where
callers are located from a height
perspective
this is especially problematic for
people living in cities the FCC is also
requiring cellphone carriers to provide
the vertical location in the 25 largest
metropolitan areas by 2021 and in the 50
largest by 2023 because of this
technology companies like Polaris
Wireless have started to detect where a
caller is located vertically let's look
at Willis Tower
Chicago's tallest freestanding building
it's 108 stories today when a responder
goes there they don't know whether the
caller is on the first floor or the
hunter Nathe floor with our solution we
can say you're on the your altitude
comes to the 76th floor and first
responders would know it's the 75th 76
or 77 they don't have to climb 108
floors looking for the caller
smartphones today have a barometer
inside that sensor can help us determine
the altitude of the device and based on
the altitude of that device we can
extrapolate how many floors you're above
ground while Polaris Wireless has it
been deployed in any call centers yet
early tests have found that they can
locate a caller within 2.8 meters 80% of
the time this would represent a big step
forward for 911 while companies race to
solve this problem how fast 9-1-1 can
find you still depends a lot on where
you live which carrier you have and what
technology your local 911 center has
embraced
you